welcome to part three of my 6x6 tutorial
at this point all of your centers should
be properly positioned and oriented
correctly so that red black and blue are
in a clockwise direction opposite of red
you should have orange opposite of black
you should have yellow and opposite of
blue you should have green you might
also have white stickers if you have the
black cube if your centers are not
correct at this point please rewatch
steps one and two for instructions on
how to fix them before proceeding what
we're going to do in this part is learn
how to pair the edge pieces of the 6x6
cube as I have said in the first video
there are 12 sets of edge groups
composed of four pieces with two inner
edges and two outer edges the way I'm
going to teach how to pair the edges is
to start from the inside and work your
way out we're going to first pair the
inner edges and then we're going to pair
the outer edges to the inner edges this
beginner technique will utilize methods
from solving the 4x4 and also the 5x5
cube edges I'm going to explain the
general concept however I'm not going to
go through pairing every edge with you
my 4x4 tutorial part 2 and 5x5 tutorial
part 3 cover edge pairing in more detail
and can be found on my channel playlist
once you have paired the edge pieces
you'll then need to fix any edge parity
which I will also explain in this video
alright so what are the similarities
between a 4x4 cube and a 6x6 cube well
they're both even layered cubes this one
has 4 this one has 6 the 4x4 has 12 sets
of 2 edge pieces or twenty four edges
total while the 6x6 cube has 12 sets of
four edge pieces or 48 edges total the
number of the inner edges on the 6x6
cube however is the same as the amount
of edges on the 4x4 cube so there are 24
total inner edges so what does that mean
well this means that you can pair the
6x6 inner edges the same exact way as
you would the four by four cubes edges
so how would you go about solving the
4x4 Cube edges well you find two
identical edges this one has white and
blue on it and this
also has white and blue on it you set
them on opposite ends of the cube this
one's on the left and this one's on the
right you'll also notice they have
different colors on the front so this
one has blue on the front and white on
the side while this one has white on the
front and blue on the side and they are
in opposite layers this one's on the
inside up and this one's on the inside
down once they're positioned like that
you can match them up by twisting the
one on top over to the one on the bottom
you could also twist the one on the
bottom over to that way but for
simplification I'm going to show it this
way so I would move this one over to
that edge now you notice they're pair up
however the centers have been misaligned
so what you do is you want to get this
newly matched pair out of the way and
replace it with any other unmatched pair
so that we can realign the center's so
once we match it up you lift it and
replace it with an unmatched pair now
you'll notice the center's are
misaligned so you have to bring that
unmatched pair back down and then you
could realign the center's and you don't
have to worry about breaking that newly
matched pair up so that's the beginner
method and what that does is it gives us
one newly matched pair alright so let's
start pairing the inner edges of the 6x6
cube what you want to do is you want to
find two identical edge pieces just like
you do in the 4x4 cube so here I have an
inner black and white edge piece and
here's another inner black and white
edge piece so what you do is you set
them up so that ones on the inside up
layer ones on the inside down layer this
one's on the left this one's on the
right
this one has blue on front and black on
the side while this one has black on
front and blue on the side then you just
do the same exact thing you pair them up
by twisting three layers now instead of
two so we want to twist all three of
these layers just like that once they're
paired you need to get them out of the
way and replace them with an unmatched
pair so you lift it up twist it out of
the way with an unmatched pair in this
position now you bring it back down and
then you just realign the center's so
there we have two
um pieces which are now next to each
other looking around the cube again you
want to find two again so here I have an
inner red and black piece here's another
red and black piece so if this one's
here on the inside up layer we can get
this one here on the inside down layer
so you bring this one down flip that
over there and then bring it up now
you'll see this inner up layer pieces on
the right and this ones on the left so
we just do the opposite we bring it this
way now so you pair it up and then you
get it lift it up
look on top you want to replace it with
an unmatched pair and then you bring it
back down then you could twist the
center's back to realign them so you
want to keep on doing that over and over
again until you have either two sets of
pieces which are left in that case there
should be two pairs left that you need
to match up that would indicate you have
a parity error now the parity error on
the 6x6 cube is going to be exactly the
same as the parity error on the 4x4 cube
since we are now organizing the inner
edge pieces of the 6x6 cube so you want
to keep on edge pairing until you find
that you have a parity error so here I
have another edge piece here's orange
and black I usually like to choose the
black ones because they're a little bit
easier to spot so we pair this piece up
which is actually already set up to be
paired with this one so you pair it up
get it up and out of the way and bring
down an unmatched pair and then you
realign the center's all right so keep
on doing that until you have two sets or
until you complete match it completely
matched all of the inner edge pieces all
right at this point you should have
tried to match up as many inner edge
pieces as possible you're either going
to be able to match up all twelve pairs
or you're going to have two pairs left
in which case you have a parity error
this is the same exact parity area that
you see on the 4x4 cube so as you'll see
you really can't pair these up because
even if I try to pair this up to that
there's no other unman
payers left and you'd wind up breaking
one of the already matched payers that
you have so to fix this you want to get
the identical pieces to be on the same
layer as you'll see this orange blue
pieces on the top and this is on the
bottom here
so to get them in the same layer you
just bring this down flip that over
there and then bring this back so now
that they're in the same layer they both
have orange on the front face and these
both have green so what you want to do
is perform this algorithm to fix this
error turn all three down layers
clockwise turn the right face clockwise
turn the front face counterclockwise
turn the up face clockwise turn the
right face counterclockwise turn the
front face clockwise and turn all three
bottom layers counterclockwise so as
you'll notice these two pairs have now
been fixed and you can move on preparing
the outer edge pieces of the 6x6 cube
okay so by matching all of the inner
edge pieces on the 6x6 cube what we have
done is reduced the 6x6 cube edges to a
5x5 cube edges as you'll see if these
two pieces are visualized as one piece
it's going to be the exact same thing as
solving the 5x5 cube edges so if you
want to solve the 5x5 cube edges you get
two identical edge pieces opposite ends
of the cube just like you do with the
4x4 then you would bring this piece over
to this middle edge piece you want to
get two unmatched edge pieces now in
this position so that you can bring the
center's back and realign them so once
it's matched you bring it up twist it so
that an unmatched pair is here and then
bring it back down now
when you twist this back you want to
make sure that these two pieces do not
have a matched up edge if you do you're
going to break it up when you realign
the center's so these two pieces are not
matched as you'll see so I bring it back
and now I have one newly matched edge
pair so it's the same exact thing on the
on the 6x6 cube
so what you want to do is you want to
get a middle-aged pair across from a
single outer edge piece so here I have
red on the front and black on the front
here you want to have the opposite
orientation then you can match it up by
twisting these two top layers now I have
three matched up so then I bring this up
and out of the way
and twist and unmask pair here and bring
it back down so now with this back this
blue white edge piece doesn't belong
with these two anyway so it doesn't
matter so you want to keep on doing that
looking around the cube you want to find
two pieces which you can match up I'm
going to consider this one piece so if I
want to match up this orange black piece
to these two I do the same thing as
you'll see it's already set up properly
so all I have to do is twist it lift it
up out of the way so that I have an
unmatched pair in its place and then
bring that back down to realign the
center's so you just want to keep on
doing that over and over again here I
have an outer blue white piece
I'm sorry blue yellow and here is the
inner edge pair so bring it down over
now they're opposite each other so I
pair it get it up out of the way and
bring it down realign the center's same
thing now I have this other edge outer
blue yellow piece and I can match it
with these three get them opposite pair
it up lift it up twist it so that an
unmatched pair is here and bring it back
down realign the center's so you want to
do that over and over until you have two
sets of four edges which have parity
errors or you might have been been able
to solve all of the edges all right
there are three main types of last edge
group cases that I'd like to go over for
solving the last edge groups of the 6x6
cube you can again visualize this inner
edge group as one piece on the 5x5 so
this parity error in which you see this
one piece is flipped it says this is the
exact same case that you see on the 6x6
cube so to correct this you want to hold
this last edge group on the top layer
all the way in front as it is here then
you're going to perform the following
algorithm both right faces twice the
back face twice the up face twice both
left faces clockwise the up face twice
both right faces counterclockwise the up
face twice both right faces clockwise
the up face twice the front face twice
both right faces clockwise the front
face twice both left faces
counterclockwise the back face twice and
both right faces twice and as you'll see
that parity error in which this inner
edge group was flipped in comparison
with these out or to add edge pieces is
now corrected and you can go on to solve
the cube like a 3x3 all right so this
next case is a case that we also see on
the 5x5 cube and as you'll see these two
wing edges or outer edge pieces need to
be switched so in order to fix this what
we're going to do is we're going to take
both of these edge groups and put them
on the top face now the way that we want
to hold it is we want these two wing
edges or outer edge pieces all the way
to the right on the top face then we're
going to perform the following algorithm
in order to correct this error so both
left faces counterclockwise the up face
twice both left faces counterclockwise
the up face twice the front face twice
both left faces counterclockwise the
front face twice both right faces
clockwise the up face twice both right
faces counterclockwise the up face twice
and both left faces
twice and as you'll see that parity
error has now been corrected the last
main case that we see is a case that
also occurs on the 5x5 cube and it is
actually not a parity error but can be
easily solved with the same algorithm
that we used for fixing the inner edge
parity on the 6x6 cube that's also the
same algorithm that you use to fix the
edge parity on the 4x4 now the algorithm
will look slightly different since we
are turning different layers there is a
way that you need to position these edge
pieces before you do the algorithm you
want to find the triple edge piece and
you want to find the outer edge piece
that needs to go with it you want to get
them to have the same color on the front
face so this has orange on the front and
this last piece has orange on the front
also if they were positioned like this
you couldn't perform that algorithm so
you want them to have the same color on
the front face once you have them
arranged like that you want this last
edge piece to be on the top so if it was
positioned like this once you got these
to have the same color you just want to
flip it over so that this is here in the
upper right now if you have it in the
upper left you're going to do the
algorithm which I'll provide in the
video description which is the just the
opposite of this algorithm so the
algorithm that you need to correct this
case is both down faces clockwise the
right face clockwise front face
counterclockwise the up face clockwise
the right face counterclockwise the
front face clockwise and both down faces
counterclockwise and now that case has
been corrected alright guys so now that
you have all of your center's and your
edge pieces matched up you have
basically reduced these six by six cube
to a 3x3 and can solve it like one
however since the six by six is an even
layered cube we will also see parity
errors while solving the cube as a 3x3
my final part four will cover how to
visualize the cube when solving it as a
3x3 and we'll also explain how to
correct these last parity errors thanks
for watching